des horaires à rallonge des patients
expédiés mais surtout un tarif de
consultation jugé bien trop faible les
médecins généralistes tombent la blouse
et ce livre plus question de travailler
dans ces conditions une partie d'entre
eux notamment chez nous ce sera donc le
travail demain et vendredi les
c'est à nous la médecine libérale tire
la sonnette d'alarme
grève pour prévenir sur leurs conditions
de travail et alerter notamment sur un
point crucial la désertification
médicale
l'essentiel de la motivation c'est que
chaque cabinet qui ferme aujourd'hui
est à la lumière derrière lui il y a de
moins en moins de médecins qui
s'installe et comme il y a de plus en
plus de médecins qui arrivent à l'âge de
la retraite il y a une vraie crise de
l'accès aux soins aux soins de proximité
dans notre pays au cœur des
revendications une revalorisation du
prix des consultations en passant de 25
euros à 50 pour permettre l'embauche
d'assistants médicaux ou de secrétaire
pour alléger la charge administrative et
donc le quotidien des médecins libéraux
on est en droit de s'interroger sur
est-ce que dans 10 ans nos jeunes
confrères accepteront de travailler
comme on travaille actuellement le
Conseil de l'Ordre ne peut que
légitimement
comprendre et entériner les
revendications de nos confrères libéraux
qui sont en grande partie bien légitimes
de nombreuses fermetures de cabinets
sont donc à prévoir jeudi et vendredi
l'agence régionale de santé incite à
limiter les consultations uniquement à
celles qui ne peuvent pas attendre la
fin de la grève et en cas de doute ne
pas hésiter à composer le 15